[Musique]
j'ai mal parti c'est ici
au 2 octobre au liban du maroc
je me sens bien dans ma ville de sens
horenstein des brocolis mines m afrika
afrika afrika l'esclave has doute
l'identitaire libéré en 1835 toujours
esclave dans nos pensées en 2019 skis
malaise créole toujours existé sous
représentation politique doute
l'identité minorité ipod touch of skulls
opens eyed peas justin est prévenant si
synthetic drogue comme sanction
jeudi li me dire firent 10 représente 10
croyons comme inédit malaise créole
l'avancement creo les skis boutoir
vienne cause pas dit stop finkin
inquiète make it any further méquignon
savent papeete at the past office rich
dans un kiosque ou mauvaises
si on te parle avec des flammes répond
l'heure avec des mots comment veux tu
que je me calme
toute notre histoire n'a été que monnet
trade vente capture après avoir voyagé
de négriers en négrier de parents port
que nous sommes mélanger pour perpétuer
l'espèce métissé le land n'occulte
millénaire nos cultures
et élisez le pratiquer vos frères
brothers sisters grizzly bear haye de
riz 5 min dhabi tunis of genetic memri
gâteau gaffe
breach of dead space
comment veux tu que reality daquino
longue et shane haley sinon
environnement unique et phreaking chez
mais sort de ma tête de time has come
now to meet the needs to be watching
comment veux tu que je fasse abstraction
de tant d'atrocités
on nous a menti sur notre culture
pant métis s'en mêler
comment veux tu comment on veut tuer j
comment veux tu que l'été racines et de
l'histoire de notre chère mère patrie
comment veux tu que j'efface de ma
mémoire
les fondus de l'indépendance pour les
bonnes tables et mon mollet monde pas
tout le monde nous faudrait dit non non
wavy langue créole mauricien créole
africain we are one will dreaming of
death and political representational mix
iqw un seuil conomique hommes bichonnent
l'esclave doute l'identité et au web
sont morts après qu'un enfant en afrique
quel mode du son dancefloor des 312
magnifique african rights naissance aux
bills 12 juges et nay george vi aux kits
ex chef du globule afrique économie
united of dit baye lodges je suis crépus
et je suis créole jeu suicider et je
suis plein je suis métisse et je suis
juin
je suis je suis moi moi je suis 1810 je
suis tue 10 945
je suis 1968
je suis 1999 indépendant jeunes de la
république tu me parle de mon avenir mon
passé je le connais même pas penses tu
qu'il nous faut seront à l'exode pense
du fait qu'on sera obligé d'aller nous
planter ailleurs à ions d'autres terres
assez nos bureaux
cette chaufferie malaise créole il fut
c'est nous les montrent